s'est passé ce soir
à paris dans une cathédrale notre dame
un terrible drame
avoir une pensée
des remerciements
pour les sapeurs pompiers de paris
centre depuis plusieurs heures seront
bâtis contre les flammes et se battre
encore et le font encore pendant des
heures et des heures et des heures et
sans doute plusieurs
qu'ils ont fait avec un courage extrême
un grand professionnalisme
de détermination de la part de l'arjel
veux ici
dir les romains
ciment de la nation tout entier
durant six heures grâce à leur
engagement à l'engagement de l'ensemble
des services de l'état de la mairie de
paris
les personnels de notre dame
pire a été évité même si
la bataille n'est pas encore totalement
gagné
[Musique]
mais grâce à leur courage
la façade
la note totale
alors je veux
soir avoir bien entendu avant tout
une pensée pour les catholiques les
catholiques
france et partout à travers le monde
en particulier
[Musique]
ils ressentent
aussi avoir une pensée pour toutes les
parisiennes et les parisiens
notre dame de paris
[Musique]
c'est leur cathédrale et plus encore
madame le maire de paris et a vécu ses
heures
flammes
son émotion
[Musique]
veut aussi avoir une pensée pour
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
parce que notre dame de paris c'est
notre histoire
notre littérature notre imaginaire
le lieu où nous avons vécu tous nos
grands moments
nos épidémie nos guerres de libération
c'est l'épicentre
de notre vie
c'est l'étalon du parthe les distances
et de londres se mesure depuis paris
ces temps de livres de peinture
cathédrale qui est
celle de tous les français mais de tous
les français même celles et ceux qui n'y
sont jamais vu
c'est la nuit
alors elle fondu
elle brûle il ya des jeux c
seysses
ce tremblement intérieur ressentie par
tant de nos concitoyens
ce soir je veux
aussi avoir un mode espérances
[Musique]
pour nous tous et plus
cette espérance c'est la fierté que nous
devons avoir
fierté
ceux qui se sont battus
pour que le pire ne viennent pas
ces soldats du feu
fierté parce que cette cathédrale il n'y
a plus de 800 ans
nous avons su l'édifice
et à travers les siècles la faire
grandir et l'améliorer alors je vous le
dis très solennellement ce soir
cette cathédrale nous la rédaction
tous ensemble
et c'est sans doute une part du destin
français
et le projet que nous aurons pour les
années à venir mais je m'y engage
dès demain
une souscription nationale sera lancée
et bien au-delà de nos frontières nous
ferons appel
grand talent et ils sont nombreux qui
viendront y contribuer
mais nous rebâtirons
bâtirons notre dame
parce que ce
parce que c'est ce que notre
[Musique]